was sagt man da ich freue mich für euch
danke danke also joe und ich will ich
weiß ja seit geschäftspartner weißt du
was für wichtiger ist ich habe den
auftrag für das shooting 60.000 ach so
ich würde dich gerne um eines bitten
könntest du ry alex events bitte nicht
erzählen dass marco nicht verlobt sind
also fürs erste ich möchte einfach
gerade vermeiden dass ich den job
bekommen wegen markt weiß schon
natürlich nicht wir haben die hat
zugesagt bevor wir es wissen
da wir sehr dankbar es wird auch für
mich zeit zu gehen dann sehen wir uns ja
bald kollegen bleibt doch noch bitte wir
wollen später noch freien
doch auch was heißt ja also franz ist
praktisch sind legendär wirklich
übertreibt nie ich mich dass ja bild
machen danke aber nein danke
du bist du ich brauch dich
das gleiche habe ich auf deine mailbox
gequatscht die habe ich noch gar nicht
abgehört
wenn ihr vor seiner wohnungstür ist
unterwegs
gleich motorrad schnell ins büro da
steht man macht das ich warte solange
das gleich was machst du noch im büro
alex lucas was machst du hier
ich wollte mal schnell was ausdrucken
mein drucker ist defekt und alex wo ist
er
wir haben es nach der vernissage
verabschiedet jetzt geht es mir wirklich
leid ich war sonst nicht an einen
anderen rechner gehen aber ich musste
dieses angebot unbedingt fertig kriegen
aber gegen frage was machst du denn
nicht so spät noch hier
das was passiert nein nein nein mein
fahrrad steht unten in der garage und
der schlüssel liegt herum
na dann los macht übrigens die
entscheidung für das fotoshooting wegen
der models war ich so schnell wie
möglich bitte denkt